it's out dude I've been working on this
for so long I don't even know it's so
satisfying
Billy Eilish freaking out after her
first album dropped I mean you're
breaking spotify records you're breaking
Apple music records this album is
supposed to sell I think over 300,000
copies are you ready for the next level
of superstardom no no I think I am
honestly no I think I I feel like
Destiny's eg was there to see it all at
the Billy Eilish experience a pop-up
event for die-hard fans in LA I know
everybody the Billy Eilish experience
events whatever the you want to call it
is officially open to the room check
them out tell me what you think actually
don't cuz I don't give up what you think
this is epic what does it feel like to
know that Spotify is willing to do this
for you I mean it's funny because
sometimes you you dream about something
and you might write it down you might
tell people and be like this is what I
want you know in my wildest dream and
then I did that and here which is like
it's so crazy because yesterday I came
by for the first time to like to see
everything in person and it just was
like everything that I've wanted it to
be for this whole time it's literally
like I stepped into my own brain like in
person each room represents a different
song on the album and was curated by
Billy every single room is literally
stepping into my mind stepping into the
way that I create the way that I the way
that I build and the way that my brain
works so I hopefully you can see it the
way that I see it and appreciate it the
way that I appreciate it and just know
that it's it's a dream come true in the
you should see me in a crown room you're
surrounded by big screens projecting
images of spiders but you also see
for all good girls go to hell you're
encroached by planes or wish you were
gay everything is lime-green including
the cutout shapes of people against the
walls the when the party's over room is
a total party where fans can jump into
this foam pit like I did there's also a
bonus room called 8 where you can play
with and adopt puppies from Molly's
mutts
I clearly never wanted to leave for my
strange addiction you can sit and do
arts and crafts and of course the berry
a friend room is as haunting as you
might expect with the album name a lyric
from the song splashed across the dark
walls on stage the 17 year olds also
revealed there was a secret room
dedicated to her mom in honor of her
birthday my mom is the main thing I have
to think the main person had something
for everything and tomorrow is her
birthday so there's a room dedicated to
her but she doesn't know it yet and um
we wanted to sing happy birthday happy
birthday happy birthday
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]